مواقيت
[موسيقى]
في بريطانيا قد يغلق فيه اصحاب المحل
التجاريه
بلاك بوليتوقعوا الذهاب الناس
للمخدراتها تنفذ اليها
320,000 شخص خلال الاشهر السته الماضيه
طلبا للمساعده واقع قاسم تقابله للحكومه
الجديده زياده الضرائب وخفض الانفاق بقيمه
55 مليار جنيه
وهكذا كان تعليق وزير الماليه البريطانيه
البريطاني بالاحاديث وكل ما يفكر به هو
كيف سيتجاوز الشتاء قادما برودته تصل قبله
ليس المواطن البريطاني فقط وانما الاوروبي
بشكل عام فهنا فرنسا شركات كبيره تتجه لاع
الافلاس والسبب لا يزال ازمه الطاقه
فواتير الكهرباء مرتفعه الطاقه شحيحه
نسبيا قياسا بالسيناريو الاسود كارثه
اقتصاديه كبرى تلوح في الافق بالطبع حاول
وزير الاقتصاد والماليه الفرنسي في رد على
سؤالي مراسل العربيه
خفيفه من وطئتها
نوسه